could uh just make a start please uh so
welcome councillors and members of the
public joining us on youtube to torres
district council's annual general
meeting
uh the first item of business is
apologies for absence
thank you it's councillor harding and
councillor
apologies okay thank you
the second item is the election of chair
of council could i have any proposals
answer james
is hobson
yes i'd like to uh second the nomination
for councilmember
we are in safe hands with him
council jones to keep
are there any other proposals
nope so if we could go to the boats
please pull those in favor
uh
okay any against
okay
sorry my wife
is this one on that yes
declaration is i don't respect me having
been elected to the office of chair of
taurus's council he clearly take that
office upon myself and i will duly and
faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the rest of my judgment
well thank you for your confidence in me
thank you very much it is appreciated
the second item on the agenda
is to elect the vice chair of pencil
from the chair of that would nominate uh
cancer repeater questioning
are there any other nominations
i can have a second repeat council chain
seconded
my show fans in favor please
tables
uh i picked christie having been elected
to the office vice chair of torres
district council
declared that i take the office upon
myself and will do the
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
to say thank you councillors and uh
100.
[Laughter]
the item four on the agenda is uh public
contributions and there are no public
speakers that i'm aware of
number five
consider correspondence or other
business brought forward by the
direction of the chair
again i don't have any
no
item six
is the election
of the leader of the council
we've got nominations
any nominations councillor hicks
thank you mr chairman uh i'm gonna
propose ken james carry on for another
year
uh he's been a good steady hand for a
year or two at it now
uh the farm has gone directly ruined but
[Music]
okay are there any other nominations
if not go to the phone please show us in
favor
and again
okay
[Music]
item seven on the agenda is uh
the election of the deputy leader of the
council
mr james
thank you chair um
[Laughter]
i need somebody to keep me in order
thank you
any other nominations
okay we're good with the vote then all
in favor michelle
okay
yeah and against
abstentions
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you're suggesting
yeah there is a slight anomaly actually
on page four
um second one from the bottom property
and major project working group is meant
to have only four members
um yet there are quite a few more just
turn up and vote so i'm not sure
i'm sure it will be
um yeah
there needs to be under the constitution
four members of it um and we are one
short and we have a proposal that will
come up later on and convert the full
agenda and you'll see there is a
proposal for that
but as anyone who's on the projects
meeting last week um when we talked
about it as far as i'm concerned
everybody turns up as an equal say that
we do need for the constitution to have
the four members
[Music]
thank you
james
[Music]
indeed
councilman county
thank you
is
okay item nine is
allocation of
seats to the vertical group stages 22-23
[Laughter]
because um there was no presentation
required we're just going to go straight
into proposing executive but
um yeah this one is to
approve the allocation of seats to
political groups on each committee um
the allocations are set out on
page 22. um so the recommendation is
that members approve or not of the case
may be the political balance on each
committee
[Music]
i would like to propose the
recommendations set out only 22.
all in favor
[Music]
membership of committees
[Music]
i'd like to propose
off of ordinance and governance because
he's on ons inter external and you can't
be on one s handbag in june so um he
will step down and cancel
um
[Music]
a second that i'm very grateful to our
leader for sorting that matter out
nothing is an excellent job at all in
the governance but uh it's just a clash
of scrutiny can't do all the governance
and uh wish you well on your ordinance
and government's pressure packet so i
second what uh our leaders just said
thank you very much
sorry chad just pointed out nothing
about against the individuals being
discussed but as this individual
committee
membership surely that's for the group
leaders to assign it's not normally done
through full council
[Music]
it's a choice
yeah just just to clarify so and the
recommendation in the report is it's
either agreed as per the membership of
committees on page 26 or that role is
delegated to group leaders um i think
councillor james is switching an
independent for an independent um so i
think as group leader he would make that
recommendation
so it doesn't need us to actually
endorse it
right
okay thank you very much
well supported
[Music]
apparently we still need a vote it's
been proposed and separated
just just to clarify it's on
the committee membership on page 26 with
the amendment proposed by councillor
james
that councillor hodgdon b
um
put on external um sorry auditing
governance as opposed to council
pennington but
that's fine it's been proposed and
secretary clinton's favorite place
[Music]
no
[Music]
right so the first one we've got is c r
[Music]
unless there's any other nominations
on the golf thank you very much mr
chairman i'd like to nominate council
brenton um chairman of cnr i think he
did the best job of the council
[Music]
[Music]
supporters
[Music]
so we've got an again
right
that's three again
abstentions
four
alright
[Music]
is that a correct procedure please just
guidance nothing against
any names mentioned to you here but as
he proposed coach the president and then
therefore keeps saying
counselor brandon hasn't been proposed
you'll
[Music]
okay the next one is a vice chair of cnr
are you um to propose
someone anyone i am indeed
proposed counselor
we need some youth from cnn
she's done a damn good job very handy
to get hold of
uh
thank you
how's the goal
okay
[Music]
are there any other nominations
if not we'll put it to the vote please
[Music]
against
and abstentions
thank you
the next one is foreign governance chair
nations we'll put it to the vote please
show all in favor
of this thank you
all right moving on to audit and
governance vice chair
um i would like to propose cancer ruth
crady she's done an excellent job
um
solidly all the right ways
for brendan seconded
okay are there any other nominations
okay put it to the vote please all in
favor
are she anonymous again thank
the you one is the plans chair
mr james can i propose that cancer
letter continues as chairman of plans
you should be counting cash
second that please chair thank you are
there any other nominations
if not but it didn't hold all in favor
[Music]
you're anonymous again
[Music]
you happy with that question
and
she's probably by far the most
experienced and knowledgeable person
thank you for that have we got a second
of these
yeah
i would second council a lot
thank you very much
are there any other nominations sorry
question
i was going to balls counts a lot but
the junk
jumped in in front of me yeah can i just
take this opportunity to thank
councillor margaret brown she's not here
tonight
for all the work she's doing his vice
chair of plans not only in this
uh cancer
but i think for eight years previously
she chaired her vice chair of plans i'd
just like to record meditate please the
thanksgiving as a counselor
thank you very much for that
okay there have been no other
nominations there's been proposing
seconded we have shorthands in favor
please
thank you
okay now come on to uh the license and
chair
licensing
as wholesome i'd like to propose uh
jamie mckenzie continues as the
licensing chair thank you
thank you
are there any other nominations
i'd like to propose councillor club
to who has served very well on um
uh that
she should take on um
thank you you have
a second counselor
yeah
so
councillor mckenzie has been duly
proposing second becoming shelf hands in
support of that place
okay
again
thank you much
[Music]
okay left to do that again let's um
counsel we can so constant mckenzie has
been reported
on second date canada
has in favor of this in support
[Music]
thank you
licensing vice chair
actually newton
i'd like to replace the clock that's uh
vice chair of licensing okay
thank you
any other nominations question mckenzie
should i nominate their counselors
that was the first one
on again
abstentions
[Music]
so this is the
four
country clock
fifth proposed the second one yeah this
is four times
in one hand
extensions
and favor uh
abstentions
twenty against and one abstention
counselor wiseman twenty one four
nine against and one abstention
including carrie in favor of counseling
thank you
next on the list is internal scrutiny
chair
mr wiseman thank you
thank you everybody
um i'd like to oppose councillor watson
please
and i'll be more than happy to second
them
from the chair
any other nominations
okay we'll put it to the vote in favor
fighter based
right
against
extensions
second
[Music]
any other nominations
okay let's put it all in favor please
okay and again
on extensions
two three obsessions
yes
let's carry them
[Music]
next one is external scrutiny chair
sure
that's it that's another
as i report counter the dual monthly
because she's doing a very good job
thank you again
and i'd like to second that thank you
thank you
any other nominations
okay put it to the vote then please
don't support
[Music]
[Music]
are there any other nominations
that's from corporate content in our
absence
okay what 12 hands all in favor of this
support
machine
sorry
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay the next item is uh standards
committee chair council james i'd like
to propose council laws continue
um
he's done a very good job and a
difficult circumstance
thank you very much any other
nominations
please
against
abstentions
[Music]
the next thing on the agenda is
standards committee vice chair
yeah
you said that that's the rules
very much my notion of being innovative
[Laughter]
[Music]
brenton who's got more experience of
standards from both sides
[Music]
no second of all
i'm shocked
okay
are there any other nominations
put to the vote then for uh councillor
rachel clark to be the vice chair of
standards all in favor please show
um
okay again
one again
have you extensions
[Music]
your
[Music]
thank
you spike
i think 12 on agenda
is a scheme of delegation
hello
i don't know
um
another really popular person
obviously
okay item 12 is
the scheme of delegation
okay
it's to
extend the calling
period to 28 days from 21 years to
planning applications
and the reason for that is
i think we've all experienced
applications being
advertised and it's only further on
as more information comes to life
that we find out
i wish i'd call that in but 21 21 days
has gone it's not very long for 31 days
i think we ought to
extend it to 28 years
period
and the other issue is
i'd like to have the leader
uh give him the prerogative as the chief
exec and head of planning involved to
call an application in at any time
and i think there should be an elected
member have that same priority
and i would suggest that the leader has
that
lot recently
quite challenging it's quite difficult
[Music]
yeah i didn't think there's any issues
with
that i i
was considering whether we needed to
bring it forward to another council for
a full report but i can't see
any issues with councillor
um
levers proposal and
my first consideration was whether we
need to consult the planning manager but
i i think that's absolutely fine 28 days
is
not going to cause problems with the
planning system and and as council
lovers
stated
the chief exec
and the panel manager already have the
probability to call in
at any stage so i i don't see any
difficulty of the leader having that
ability also we are the full council
we're the ones that set the rules i
suppose not man
yeah i can start to agree with what
um
consider the application without calling
an extra immediate song in
chris you've got the little box for
planning members on the planning
committee to take the the third block
would that apply to the leader if they
and the chief exec
in that situation so they have to
declare either four or against but they
can call it in if they feel it is
applicable would that be extended to to
the leader if he's got the right to call
in
there's another
well
under the current uh situation the chief
exec
and uh planning manager don't have to
give a reason to call to pull an
application the same would be with the
leader
and i would i would i mean it's not very
often but i just think an elected member
should have that same priority
to call in at any stage
and i think i can think of one where the
chief exec called come in ignore them
which was a controversial only a small
application actually but it was very
controversial
and to satisfy everybody of chief
executive sponsor yeah
[Music]
transparency when you go onto the portal
you can see who calls it in and what
grows they call it in on and planning
members can call it in without having to
give reasons and that is quite important
sometimes when you're on planning
committee if you give reasons you may be
borrowed from a meeting and it has
implications
and processes transparency that you can
tick the box it can be seen by general
public who's actually called it in i
know what preference and it can be a
nominal calling because your home that
pacific decision chief exec leader or
member of the planning committee i think
what suggested is that the leader of the
council gets parity with the planning
manager and the chief executive so they
can call it in they would actually give
them a reason
as an independent person with an officer
i think that's that's an important
message i would envisage if it was used
by the leader
the prerogative or the chief exec or the
planet magic they'd give a reason why
it's called them
after the 28th year which was increasing
so
it's not a problem and it isn't used
very often
it's just that two senior officers have
got that prerogative and i just feel
after a principle an elective member
should have that same problem
[Music]
country haynes has been waiting
[Music]
one
day
it's been proposed together and seconded
together
okay we're subject to those
amendments to the uh scheme are we happy
that we accept the scheme as it is can
you show hands in favor
okay
thank you thank you okay we propose a
second all favorably sure
outside bodies
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
and i was going to propose that we
um
rather than decide this tonight the
option is to defer it to group leaders
so they can review this list
because some of these bodies no longer
exist some of them have merged with
other bodies and reformed so i think we
need to actually have a discussion about
it
and move it forward but refer it to
group leaders and i would like to
propose that
okay let's put proposed a second of that
pressure inch
as well and also
if whoever is looking at it you can look
at um because there might be other
outside
[Music]
it is deferred to uh
leaders that uh
can have a look at this and decide
whether somebody uh
deleting adding or whatever
[Music]
so they're you're also then happy to to
propose it again that it is delegated to
group leaders and leavers
[Music]
oh yeah sorry okay
so
[Music]
that it is deferred to group leaders to
revisit this uh whole list to see
whether they are relevant
is
i would like to see a reflection of wes
would be on that list as well but they
did come to
um external ons i think we need to
reflect a little bit more towards the
housing issues that are facing our areas
and our view and more organizations
we've worked within that area they've
been very active in the last 12 or 18
months giving the housing crisis and i
think would be seen to be reflecting the
needs of some of our community
so i will ask if you at least add
westwood to the list as well
can i respond to councillor pennington
please you shot it again this
list
representation by councillors
on an outside body
um westwood board
have not
to my knowledge
recently invited or extended an
invitation
to this council for representation on
that award
that ceased i believe um some years ago
and i was actually on westwood board
before i became a cancer
and the council physicians
were
uh removed from their board thank you
yeah that's right did you want to come
back just to say i mean i'm the lead
person with the uh sister's advice
i'm not on the board i just link in and
and and try
to cipher new organizations i don't
think you need to be on the board i
don't think that's the issue i think
it's the issue of working with outside
bodies providing services to our
community and housing is a vital part of
what we do as a counselor well i would
make the request that leaders look at
adding the likes of housing and
particularly westwood
[Music]
homelessness and housing and housing so
presumably if someone is going to make
contact it would be casual
normally
brenton you wanted to just uh continue
what kentucky was saying actually i was
the last counsellor on the westwood
board
they booted us all off and the
government that is infinite wisdom
silent counts as absolute use of some of
these things we needed accountants and
other such worthy professionals which
have really nothing to do with
everything before when i left some
people one came from south wales one
came from hampshire absolutely no idea
what happened in the social housing it
was absolutely disgusting and they never
let us back on again that's for sure
probably we asked too many awkward
questions
the chief executive of westwood housing
on a regular basis to discuss matters
opposing and we've also extended
invitations to other registered
providers who operate in our district to
meet with them to discuss how it matters
as well thank you chair thank you
[Music]
[Music]
is that every six months uh yes sure
yeah
currently every six months
[Music]
is
[Music]
the outside bodies need to be proposed
[Music]
take a vote on that
[Music]
lead members
casador well i'd very much like
leave members please
actually happy to send that show
[Music]
yes
okay so
they remain as they are from supports
and secondary favoritely shown
16
[Music]
yes thank you um this is to appoint the
fourth
member of the group
i'm officially to make it official at
this
and i'd like to
propose that we appoint
shirley langford who's been part of the
shadow board proceedings
and is uh a worthy
contender for the role with her
knowledge in the sporting field she
brings a lot to the table thank you
from the chair
okay i have a short house on my
thank you
okay item 17
uh appointment to property a major
projects working group
mr watson yeah can i propose chris
secondary council in laws your second in
that appointment
[Music]
yeah yeah um i'd rather this went back
to the constitutional working group we
looked at because this was actually a
very important group
um
it was the successor to the asset
management working group
where a lot of material came out and i
think that
more councillors should be on this
rather than just the four at the moment
there are more councillors turn up and
we all vote and it seems to work
i heard what our leader said earlier he
didn't mind but i like it actually
formalized that's all right
suggestion that uh proposal that
comes back to
[Music]
which group
um
she suggested the constitution working
constituted
but we've had a proposal on a secondary
that country leather is added to that
group
sorry so as soon as you say i need to
add that that working group actually
feeds into community resources so it's
not a decision decision-making body of
the council
um any decisions are then uh either
considered by cnr and recommended to
full council or taken by full council so
it's not a decision made by the council
and as council christie mentioned other
members actually attend that meeting as
do
members attend many meetings uh working
groups of the council as they're
entitled to do so
thank you okay i've been proposing
second on the show of hand
a member of that group officially
[Music]
gaps
abstentions
[Music]
right
brings us down to item 18 which is
exclusion of the public
we haven't got anything in particular
but uh i've got something that the
members asked me to allow them to read
so
okay okay
so there are no part two items
that's a mutant
i got a stiff neck that's why i find
that
point of order if i major
um a counsellor this evening
uh left as soon as he had signed in in
effect uh we council afforders
um and for the record it's quite clear
that councillor ford was not here to
represent his residence he was purely
here to keep signed on for his own
personal financial gain
um is there anything that we can do
in order to
is this acceptable is what i'm really
saying i'm enough to be looking at the
uh states but um
uh chair on the point of order i don't
think you should be listening to this
well i i said up to this individual
member how or he or she conducts
themselves in terms of attending
meetings or as if i couldn't start here
actually
need a good looking at work
for this country i've been widely
informed it's not a point of order so we
can't discuss okay thank you
okay that brings us to the end of the
meeting now what's going on